c'est ici dans cette résidence de
Montréal que sont accueillies des
centaines de demandeurs d'asile chaque
mois depuis le début de l'année près de
30 000 personnes ont emprunté le chemin
Roxane les centres d'hébergement
débordent à tel point que les refuges
pour sans-abri sont sollicités
cette année on va probablement autour de
500 et de ce nombre 10% sont des jeunes
qui vont demander la cils le refuge des
jeunes reçoit chaque nuit jusqu'à 45
personnes des sans-abris de 17 à 26 ans
de plus en plus d’entre eux sont des
demandeurs d'asile
qui sont laissés eux-mêmes sans revenus
sans carte d'assurance maladie sans rien
et qui se retrouve donc stationner dans
un refuge d'urgence
de sortie
ce jeune homme qui préfère garder
l'anonymat le vécu originaire de
l'Angola il est arrivé à Montréal par le
chemin Roxane quelques semaines avant sa
mère et sa sœur
il nous a appelé un soir racontait pour
nous dire qu'il n'avait nulle part où
aller il a finalement dormi dans un
McDonald's
mais qui commence à nous préoccuper
c'est finalement Arthur qui a accueilli
la famille ici le centre le pont est un
hébergement d'urgence pour demandeur
d'asile j'imagine qu'il y a des gens qui
que vous devez refuser
à tous les jours donc il y a des
personnes oui qui nous contactent pour
nous demander une chambre puis je dois
leur dire que je suis complet ce sont
surtout des femmes et des familles qui
habitent ici ils sont une trentaine des
personnes qui n'arrivent pas à se loger
autrement c'est le cas de Martin elle
est arrivée de Colombie avec son mari et
ses deux filles en juin ils ont obtenu
une chambre au YMCA un hébergement
offert par Québec qui n'est que
temporaire
on devait y rester qu'une semaine
explique-t-elle pronto obtenir on a eu
lieu
il fallait quitter rapidement puisqu'il
y avait du roulement au YMCA
on ressentait beaucoup de pression mais
c'était impossible de trouver un
appartement les prix étaient trop élevés
des propriétaires lui ont demandé
jusqu'à 6 mois d'avance de loyer
au bout de trois semaines ils ont
finalement atterri eux aussi au centre
lepont
ils sont tout compte fait parmi les
chanceux par exemple j'ai une famille
avec de très quatre très jeunes enfants
des bébés de 6 mois 4 ans 8 ans et 9 ans
mais moi et les deux parents qu'on dormi
dehors pendant plusieurs jours parce
qu'ils savent pas où elle est puis que
tous les centres communautaires
d'hébergement sont complets en ce moment
dans ce qu'on accueille il y en a qui
ont fait un passage sur un banc de parc
j'ai des jeunes j'ai qui sont bloqués
ici quelques mois la clé vers la sortie
est souvent un permis de travail qui
leur permet de payer un loyer mais les
délais pour l'obtenir ont explosé moi je
pense que ces personnes là ont droit à
un accueil digne et humain
qu'on puisse l'offrir au refuge c'est
très bien mais
qu'est-ce qui va arriver dans les
prochaines années